الاسرائيلي مشاهدينا مقتل جنديين نتيجه
اطلاق نار خلال حادث امني على الحدود مع
مصر وكما ذكر في حساب في خاي ادراي على
تويتر بانه جندي ومجنده قتل في هذه
العمليه بالاضافه الى مطلقه النار الذي
تحدث عنه الجيش الاسرائيلي واشارت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه بانه شرطي مصري اطلق
النار على القوات الاسرائيليه قرب الحدود
مع مصر كلها معلومات يجري تداولها بخصوص
هذه العمليه التي انطلقت في السادسه فجرا
عند معبر العوجه وما زال الاستنفار عاليا
مثل ما ذكر مدير مكتبنا من رام الله وليد
العمري وكذلك ما زالت تعتيم ربما يشوب
التفاصيل الاخرى المرتبطه بطبيعه هذه
العمليه التي اشار الجيش الاسرائيلي بانها
محاوله من قبل خليه مسلحه لتهريب المخدرات
بقيمه الف دولار كما قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
وينضم الايل الان الينا من الناصره محمد
مجادله الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه سيد
مجادله اذا كل العناصر التي توقف عندها
مدير مكتبنا وليد العمري المرتبطه
بالتعتيم وايضا
حجم الاستنفار والاجتماعات التي زرع اليها
وزير الدفاع مع المسؤولين العسكريين والان
جرى التاكيد بان جنديين اسرائيليين قتل في
هذه العمليه ما الذي يدل عليه كل ذلك
بالفعل يعني الجيش الان رسميا بان هناك
الحديث عن قتيلين مجند ومجنده في صفوفه
طبعا هذه المعلومات كانت قد وردت من ساعات
الفجر يعني بدايه هذا الحدث الامني كما
يصفه الجيش الاسرائيلي كانت قد وقعت فجره
هذا اليوم في الساعه الرابعه والنصف وصلت
دوريه اسرائيليه الى الحدود المصريه
الاسرائيليه بعد الاجتماع بان هناك محاوله
لاجتياز الحدود وعلى ما يبدو بان احد
المسلحين الذين اجتازوا الحدود فعليا تمكن
من اطلاق النار وقتل يعني المجند والمجنده
اللذين وصلات في هذه الدوريه اللافت هنا
بان قوات كبيره جدا من الجيش الاسرائيلي
كانت قد طاردت هذا المسلح الذي تمكن على
ما يبدو من الاقتباء وبعد يعني وقت ليس
بقصير من المطارده والبحث تم العثور عليه
وهو ايضا اطلق النار من جديد على الدوريه
التي وصلت وادى الى بعض الاصابات كذلك في
هذه الدوريه من المعلومات الوارده ولكن
ايضا بان احد المصابين في المره الثانيه
في الاشتباك الثاني هو مصاب بحاله خطره اي
انها حصيله القتلى فعليا لدى الجيش
الاسرائيلي مرشحه بالارتفاع او يمكن ان
ترتفع في الساعات القريبه القادمه ولكن
ايضا في نهايه المطاف الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعلن بانه تمكن من اطلاق النار وقتل هذا
المسلح الذي يجتاز الحدود المصريه وصولا
الى الاراضي الاسرائيليه هذه المعلومات
التي تاكدت اذا في الساعه الاخيره ونحن
نتحدث عن هذا الحدث الذي كان يعني قد اشغل
الجهاز الامني الاسرائيلي منذ ساعات الفجر
بما يتعلق بخلفيه هذه الحادثه الامنيه
هناك تحول على ما يبدو في الساعه الاخيره
في تعامل الجيش الاسرائيلي مع الموضوع لان
بدايه هذا الحدث وكما هو معتاد دائما
عندما نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه
يعني نعتاد ان نستمع الى الانباء عن تهريب
السلاح وتهريب المخدرات وما الى ذلك لان
في يعني انجازات الجيش وكل الحديث الذي
يصدره داخليا وحتى كذلك للاعلام
الاسرائيلي هناك حديث عن التعامل مع من
قاموا بهذه العمليه او التعامل مع خلفيه
امنيه اي ان الجيش يرمي او يحاول تصوير
هذا الموضوع الان ليس كمجرد عمليه تهريب
لاسلحه او لمخدرات او امرك هذا انما بان
هناك قصد امني او قصد قومي يمكن ان نقول
من من هذه العمليه ولذلك نحن نرى لان هناك
يعني تقييمات امنيه وزير الامن الاسرائيلي
قائد هيئه اركان الجيش كذلك ايضا هرتي
هنادي واجهات اخرى تتابع عن كثب ما يحدث
وراينا ايضا هذا البيان الذي اكده الجيش
الاسرائيلي فعليا عن القتيلين وعاده ما
يكون هذا الانتظار لعده اسباب اولا لكي
يتاكد الجيش الاسرائيلي بان هذه العمليه
الامنيه فعليا انتهت بانه لا يوجد ايضا من
ساعدوا هذا المسلح على اقتحام الحدود او
ان هناك كمين اخر يمكن ان يؤدي الى عمليه
ثانيا ايضا لان العاده او كما هو معتاد
ايضا لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يتم الاعلان
رسميا عن القتلى من الجنود حتى اخبار
عائلاتهم وحتى التاكد فعليا من ان هذه
العائلات وصلها خبر يعني خبر مقتل ابنائهم
فلذلك هذا التاخير الذي رايناه في كل هذه
الساعات على ما يبدو حتى هذه اللحظه يمكن
القول فعليا بان هذه العمليه او هذا الحدث
الامني كما تسميه اسرائيل يعني وصل الى
نهايته لا يوجد تطورات اضافيه هناك طبعا
يعني
الاسرائيلي الى اي درجه يعتبر هذا الحادث
استثنائيه
هو استثنائي بكل المقاييس اولا استثنائي
لان عمليه كهذه عاده تنتهي بمقتل المهربين
او بمقتل من يجتازون الحدود عن بعد يعني
لا حاجه اصلا لوصول الجيش في بعض الاحيان
الى هذه الدرجه هذا اولا ثانيا نحن نتحدث
عن عدد من الاصابات نتحدث عن قتيلين على
الاقل في الجيش الاسرائيلي وهذا بدون ادنى
شك ايضا يشكل يعني استثناءا كبيرا جدا في
التحضيرات والجهوزيه الاسرائيليه الدائمه
في هذه المنطقه ولذلك ايضا على هذا الصعيد
نحن نتحدث بدون ادنى شك على حدث استثنائي
نتحدث عن فشل الذري ايضا في اجهزه الامن
الاسرائيليه ان كان على صعيد الرب وان كان
على صعيد التعامل وكذلك ايضا على صعيد
الاستخبارات وهذا بدون ان نفك ايضا يعني
سيفكل مسار الان لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي لدى
اجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي يجب ان تعطي الكثير من
الاجابات على هذا الاخفاق الامني الواضح
والكبير جدا يعني نتحدث حتى هذه اللحظه
وفقه المعلومات الاسرائيليه
عن مسلح واحد الذي يتمكن من اجتياز الحدود
وهذا المسلح وحيدا تمكن من ايقاع قتيلين
وكذلك ايضا عده اصابات من بين هذه
الاصابات اصابه خطيره يعني هذا الحدث ايضا
استثنائي بكل ما يتعلق في مهاجمه وكذلك
القواعد الاشتباك مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي دائما ما يتغنى بقدرته يعني على
مواجهه ان كان العمليات الامنيه او
العمليات التهريبيه فبدون ادنى شكل نحن
نتحدث عن حدث استثنائي وغير مسبوق على
الاقل في سنوات الاخيره من حيث عدد
الخسائر من حيث امكانيه التعامل من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي ومن حيث الاخفاقات من
العثور على هذا المسلح الذي تمكن من المره
الاولى من اجتياز الحدود يعني وصولا الى
الاراضي الاسرائيليه تمكن كذلك من اطلاق
النار على الدوريه التي وصلت القتل المجلد
ومجنده وكذلك الاختباء بعد ذلك الانتظار
يعني حتى الوصول ايضا الدوريه الاخرى ومن
ثم اطلاق خيار على الدوريه الاخرى هل يمكن
ان يفسر يعني مصابين سيد مجاد له ذه
الاضاحات التي تتحدث عنها وعن الاستهداف
والوصول الى مجند جندي ومجنده وقتلهما هل
هذا سلوك مهربين برايك
هذا هو اللافت في الموضوع يعني عاده قضيه
التهريب تكون ونحن نرى دائما بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتمكن من التعامل معها
يعني باستهداف اكثر يمكن ان نقول نجاحا من
هذه المره ولذلك يمكن ان نرى بان هذا
التحول يعني على الاقل في الساعه الاخيره
ببيانات الجيش التي تصف يعني من اطلق
النار لم تصدقه بالمهرب لم تصفه بمن اخترق
الحدود انما تصفه بالمخرب وعاده ما يتعامل
الجيش الاسرائيلي مع هذه الكلمه يعني بوصف
المخربين عندما يكون الحدث له يعني صبغه
او خلفيه امنيه ولذلك نحن نرى ايضا في
قضيه التعامل هنا من قبل الجيش على ما
يبدو بان هذه العلامات علامات السؤال التي
تتحدث عنها انت ايضا يعني اثيرت لدى
الاجهزه الامنيه وفي التقييمات الامنيه
وهو لربما ما يدفع الجيش الان للنظر الى
هذه العمليه كعمليه امنيه الان بكل
الاحوال ايضا لابد من الاشاره هنا حتى وان
كانت هذه العمليه يعني ليست امنيه اعتقادي
الجيش سيرمي او سيحاول تصوير هذه العمليه
كعمليه امنيه لان هذا سيكون من السهل عليه
ان يقدم بعض الاجابات على الاقل على صعيد
الداخل الاسرائيلي بان هذه العمليه كان
مخططا لها وكانت معدبه احكام تحديدا وان
بعض المصادر تؤكد ايضا بان من اقتحم او من
اخترق هذه الحدود او اجتها كان متنكرا
بذيل الشرطه المصريه وهو اولى الجيش
المصري وهو الامر الذي صعبه على الجيش
الاسرائيلي التعامل مع هذا الموضوع لذلك
هناك حتى هذه لحظه تضارب في التقييمات
ولكن المؤكد بان الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الساعه الاخيره يحاول تصوير هذه العمليه
على انها عمليه امنيه وليست عمليه تهريب
عمليه التهريب اسلحه او مخدرات